salut tout le monde les podcasts
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par nick
clegg associés chaîne est un organisme à
but non lucratif vous savez présentement
on a une deuxième vague c'est pas tout
le monde que la chance d'avoir des
appareils électroniques pour pouvoir
étudier la maison pour travailler de la
maison je peux te montrer de chance le
donc c'est un organisme qui vont
reprendre vos appareils électroniques
vous servez plus qu'ils sont peut-être
que vous pensez que sont désuets et
d'autres vont vont pouvoir lire amorcé
il est s'arranger pour que des gens dans
le besoin qui en ont besoin ils vont
pouvoir avoir accès et un spi peut-être
que vous avez peur de laisser aller aux
objets électroniques vos appareils
électroniques pardon parce que vous avez
donnée dessus que vous voulez pas qu'ils
se ramassent dans les mêmes quelqu'un
que vous connaissez pas électronique
recycling association offre un service
de destruction d'effacement et de
destruction physique des données donc il
n'y a pas de peur que des photos
compromettantes ce ramadan l'imam
quelqu'un que vous connaissez pas donc
si vous avez des objets électroniques
chez vous que vous voulez vous départir
mais vous croyez qu'ils sont encore bons
pour servir à quelqu'un d'autre
vous pouvez aller au 1er à point ca ou
appelez au numéro 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8 3
on veut mettre toutes les informations
dans la description du podcast donc si
vous voulez planifier une cueillette
d'appareils électroniques que vous avez
chez vous que voulez vous départir
communiquer avec l'électronique ces
chaînes et merci pour le support continu
du sans filtre podcast exemple quoi des
vieux téléphones du téléphone les vieux
ordinateurs des vieux un des lives et
telle vision des choses comme ceux des
moniteurs on a tous ceux qui traînent ne
connais plus besoin mézin faut que ça
parte faut que ça parte
une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans fil dans le podcast où on parle de
ce qu'on veut avec nos invités date
c'est au yo yo soy ph quentin avec moi
dans cette semaine au sans fil de reçus
victoria charlton pour la deuxième fois
le grand retour de la fameuse youtube
buzz et experte en trucs l'om c'est
vraiment impressionnant victorieux à
quel point qui est devenue une sommité
une référence dans le domaine du tout
croire mme des cas de disparitions petit
ce qui est tellement au point qui te
guette en communication avec les
familles c'est vraiment vraiment un gros
travail de recherche points pour ses
vidéos
ceci dit ce parcours fait qu'on a parlé
de 200 corps une fois de sa chaîne
youtube de son travail de du phénomène
et rio charlton parler du fait que
cassine d'aidé qui cavard france et des
milliers personnes qui viennent le pari
d'un public amateur qui reçoit deux fois
sur sa chaîne de certaines personnes
pour la majorité
on a aussi parlé de santé mentale et qui
a été diagnostiqué avec eux un
diagnostic assuré becqueter potière
savoir de quoi il s'agit on a reparlé
vers la fin du podcast toujours un
plaisir de recevoir une belle personne
avec qui on adore jaser on a parlé aussi
de ma nouvelle fascination pour le trot
prime maintenant je comprends beaucoup
mieux l'engouement autour de tout ça
maintenant que moi même je tombais un
petit peu dans le trou du lapin il ya
quelque chose d'attirant d'effacement là
dedans même si morbide qui s'est donc
ouais moi c'est vrai exact écoutez
suivez nous sur son pétrole en fait
abonnez-vous aux pitchouns parce que
achat après chaque podcast on fait
encore moins de filtres ou est ce qu'on
parle la discussion qu'on mène à voir on
vient détourner aujourd'hui écoutés
c'est intéressant
écoutez je veux pas je peux vendre la
peau de l'ours le mais c'est intéressant
tout cas qu'on parle c'est qu'un camp
par faut écouter
un portail bombe à castres
[Musique]
god merci là dessus merci à vous les
grandes époques avec souvent fait qu'il
faut en profiter quand elles font que ce
scénario n'est présent maison l'année
passée crise m'a dit comme ça il ne put
rien n'est pas déjà on va fêter un
anticorps [ __ ] bientôt décembre macky
sall que le moment commencé chez nicole
s'est inscrit à une manifestation c'est
la fin 9h10 paris
c'est juste pour la douche le départ de
rama nos fans pour sedan peut-être
peut-être pas cette action nom de m
moi je suis je suis en ce moment là je
suis dans la pire passe pratiquement ma
vie pour mon optimisme global je suis
trop je sais pas pourquoi peut-être
parce que c'est là peut-être que c'est
parce qu'elle ne serait ce qu'avec le
podcast je suis plus fort mais formé par
rapport à ce qui se passe j'ai je tombé
par hasard sur une passion pour la
politique américaine dans les dernières
années mais cela paiera les pots est
intéressé et puis toutes les affaires
qui sont arrivés dernièrement le machu
samad école c'est pour elle et les
dernières semaines george tellement
pessimistes par rapport à ce que je
pense qu'à la fin d'un mauvais cycle
puis je pense c'est vraiment cyclique
des périodes plutôt une espèce débats
entre la gauche et la droite petit mais
je pense que quand même ton stress une
droite
je pense qu'on s'en vont dans la bonne
direction pillon dans un creux puisse
avoir montré ce que je dis c'est pas la
fin du monde mais c'est la fin du cycle
si ça avait tant fait c'est la
génération qui arrive là ça va être
autre chose c'est un monde plus
spirituel mais pas nécessairement
spirituel mais sa magnifique qui est le
monde doit être plus tv gamme pc avec
les animaux il va avoir le meilleur
traitement
mais le sait de quoi casser c'est quoi
tu finis mais pour quelque chose mais
moi je pense et j'espère désormais on
pense que c'est la fin du monde mais en
2000 on était convaincu en 2012 c'est
quelque chose
le mais moi j'ai pas pas que ce soit la
fin du monde imminente et mettons la
cabine ne fait pas de dire enfin que
j'en sortirai jamais de ce virus club on
est et ça s'est passé
lakovic quand même optimiste que genre
ça va on va régler ce problème là mais
j'ai apprécié c'est comme on dirait que
j'avais géré cette pensée loti mettons
dans les six mois des mesures ont fini
quelque chose que l'on n'ouvre de quoi
nous vont bien tout le temps quelque
chose d'autre c'est tout le temps
quelque chose de nouveau qui fait comme
c'est la deuxième vague non mais ça mais
si on m'avait dit c'est la théorie la
fin du monde en 2012
on avait juste eu l'an 2020 avec tout ce
qui est arrivé j'en sais pas plus a même
pas commencé de labarthe 2020 avec la
crise le sait déjà la barre des lettres
à libreville l on dirait que ça fait dix
ans mais ça fait même pas 1 à rennes que
le ramasser des fonds pour les
kangourous clicquot lcd mais ça fait
même pas un intense déjà en janvier
ouais mais je ne sais philomène entre
que là il restait trois mots la fraude
et doit croiser les doigts pour que ça
finisse mieux dispo à jardin des
présidents qui veut passer à la lippe de
guerre civile parce que les doigts les
propos de groupes extrémistes
suprémacistes blancs
si on tournait beaucoup après le débat
où est ce que tout homme qui refusait de
systématiquement les les dénoncer
puis elle a apprécié la communauté lgbt
ont repris lâche ta krabei surtout de
plasma comme d'années déjà un peu de de
bonté de coeur des réseaux sociaux de
ferraille à ce qui peut se passer aussi
le petit marc ayrault boy sur twitter
puisqu'il trend est déjà d'être d'été de
vie des personnes courir dans sa
rubrique intelligence ça c'est cool
outil le google
captain america qui sont
sa famille qui sont ces gens toutes ces
femmes dont je sais c'était quoi lyon
ils l'ont bombardé de photos de chiens
gentils août parce que lui fait faux
l'anxiété chez exemple pour quand est ce
que c'était pas un hashtag en tant que
facteur au lieu qu'on voit genre sadique
people qui était judicieux d'accord
après ça y est il écrit sur twitter
genre dire comme disparus band coupe de
jours puis est revenue sur tout et fait
maintenant que j'ai votre attention
allez votre bon fait que faisait ce qui
t'amène au québec mais j'allais faire je
suis venu enregistrer mon livre audio en
fait j'étais venu en avril c'est assez
fou parce que j'étais venu pour ça
enrichit mon livre audio et j'étais venu
pour faire tout le monde en parle en
plus ouais j'avais été loin et c'était
comme vraiment fou comme on s'entête à
tout le monde en parle c'est leur boulot
macway vraiment vraiment bi-gpu sale été
annulée mais en fait c'est parce que le
tout locaux vides puis j'avais quand
même vraiment pur et où mars avril mai
le lord est tombé en confinement comme
slogan scellés pendant deux 2 semaines
avant de faire les lives ouais j'avais
comme pure appareils parce qu'il est si
si ça existe c'est parce qu'en fait dans
sa vie son mariage
je ne sais pas parce que j'arrivais la
france puis j'avais eu mon nom et ma
séance de dédicace aux champs elysées
qui a vu comme une file de 1000
personnes
puis il y avait reçue comme ça puis on
dira qu'il faut qu'on les vitrines aux
mines mais je sais pas savouré à lui ai
passé mon premier livre met à profit net
un phénomène je sais pas mais sachez
enfin cet accord plus big c soit c'est
tout le contraire d'une personne comme
moi que une célébrité instantanée
c'est que toi ça grince agrégeant les
succès ils vont juste être de plus en
plus gros le sait moins c'est que ça
fait dans l'autre sens
[Rires]
ok j'ai tenu mon livre audio tout le
monde en parle pas puis ça a comme
toutes été annulées mais le colis est
arrivé ça le tout était annulé puis est
reparti en urgence au mexique j'ai
acheté comme mon vol
mais comme tout le monde le tout mon
truc a été annulée à cause du clavier
est effectué sur ces chevaliers jugnot
québec pour deux trois jours puis
surtout mais avec le jour venu justement
pour mon livre audio
j'en ai profité puis au mexique mais en
fait on quand confinement depuis le mois
de mars sont encore confiné le mexique
ça le portant son nom en reparlera mais
le clavier du mexique hier c'était le
numéro un le pays numéro un en termes de
morts et de jusqu'à présent aux arrêts
situés ça peut rapporter du genre et
7000 que nouveaux cas par jour et mille
morts par jour là ça même par rapport au
fait que c'est ce que j'ai fait mon
livre audio web commence et faire lire à
l'aller au complet est ce que quand tu
écris tout c'est quelque chose que tu es
laitiers comme comme le cral crachoir de
flaubert le whisky aller crier lui
écrivait c'est les aléas d'une pièce qui
appelle sur le crachoir puis avait crié
ses textes pour voir comment ça sonnait
qu'est ce que tu lis avoir des fois ce
qu'il faisait
qu'est ce que tu as été surprise par la
syntaxe
mais il ya plein de trucs qui se tait
comme à ok je me rappelais comme [ __ ]
saudemont livre ça fait quand même un an
que je décris plus d'un an
si je l'étais pas je n'étais pas déçu le
jeter dehors je sais bien que c'est
quand même bien écrit mais c'est surtout
est le maître de l'intonation j'ai quand
même habitué avec mes vidéos tg c'est de
remettre un peu de suspense comme
lacombe histoire mais
c'est vraiment vraiment épuisant c'est
sur ce souhait vous êtes quand même
habitué l' affaire des podcasts
j'imagine mais vous raconter c'est
vraiment nous regardons savoir sur des
mots c'est pas grave mais quand
j'entends faire sur un mot sur de quoi
qui collent vraiment fatigué importance
et jambon mais le metteur en fin journée
pourquoi tu leur prends tout la phrase
assassine phrase trois lignes haute et
fx est extrêmement en puisant le jeu
terminé mais c'était session de cinq
heures puis c'était comme j'ai fait
sécession de 5 eur puis à la fin de mai
journée j'étais complètement épuisé fox
a appris surtout de 30 ans pour lui et
le jeune d'avoir une obsession et
vendredi pour des corrections que jay
carney à faire évidemment puis effet que
c'était assez épuisant normalement c'est
les auteurs lis pas nécessairement leurs
livres mais là vu que bon c'est chez
youtube aux usagers qui vont avec c'est
plus intéressant pour les lecteurs et
des liaisons aussi moi je pense que je
suis pas mauvaise en français parce que
donc on étudie theresa may à l'oral je
t'ai déjà pris des cours de diction pas
plus que le diction puis tu te rends
compte que tellement de règle pieds
tellement de petites choses qu'on fait à
l'oral instinctivement mais quand tu lis
un texte mais comme à dire toutes les
syllabes mais faut pas jeter des
centaines chose qu'il faut lier mais
d'autres choses non exactement si j'ai
ce poste fait attention à la
prononciation perds ton accent mais ce
le cas tu n'as pas sa seule c'est un
cauchemar
comme quoi maintenant si mettons les
gens qui font des doublages sont formés
pour son cadre de structures et de régis
de langue à l'autre par les familiers
par les québécois surnommé normative
parler de france pis si si si c'est un
subtil pepy city pour avoir juste
mettons tu prononces poté a eu la bonne
façon plus à savary le cefac mais je
parlais comme moi là aussi c'est pas
bien mais je parlais pas familier tank
sommet
et ça mais j'ai vraiment pris les livres
il y avait une fille qui m'a aidé un peu
avec les liaisons le mais j'ai pas été
coaché non mais j'espère j'ai vraiment
pris le je pense à ses coûts admettons
mais le résultat final ça doit combien
de temps à temps quand et que ton livre
d'un buteur je sais pas j'ai réagi payer
je l'écouterai pas moins non je peux
lire
mais ça me scie intéressant quand même
c'est un gars comme comme processus mais
sur la tête et on voudrait que dans ma
tête du imagine soit comme immense le
thème charge de travail
c'est comme je peux même pas imaginer
quand on dirait que juste de les en
ligne c'est tellement long mais c'est
quand même de voir leur frère puis
petite salle en blouse bleue de phares
dit cet insurgé à chaque fois reprendre
une phrase pleuré pendant trois ans corp
la reprendre encore mieux mais c'est
aussi de quelques despatie quand je fais
mes vidéos le plus petit jeu peut
reprendre la même phrase dix fois leurs
maris fille je m'en fous je m'en fous
c'est vraiment épuisant mais j'étais
tout seul d'un grave mais la fille le
jardinage mecs que je suis vraiment
désolé moi je suis cash épuisé
mentalement ça paraît vraiment comment
je parle puis je suis pilote bouge plus
ton manteau y accroche c'est ton
chandail accroche le chemin des filets
bref il y en a qui étaient ici tout ce
qu'on se met à faire des vidéos non moi
je les fais souvent en avant samedi
matin faire du stock
un barman parce que tu as comme fait un
genre une semaine moi j'étais sorti en
vidéo par jour mais que savez combien de
vidéos en banque
et comme une dizaine même plus neeskens
vidéo qui aimait se fait sur moi que
c'est pas des vidéos ou des vidéos y en
ait une qui s était ni des eaux du nord
le jeu très intense à moi je travaille
fort le pardon comme deux mois que j'en
sais du 12 heures par jour
7 jours/semaine qui après le jeu comme
plus relax mon avantage pourtant relax
parce que je suis et
mais bref je tapais dans un genre de
c'est parce que on s'entend que tu fais
pas jardin des délices qui fait des
estives de des vidéos qui sont longues
sont étoffées qui demande la recherche
quand tu fais du 12 heures par jour à
lire sur des histoires sordides tu
deviens dessus genre que cette fin mais
j'ai vraiment une carapace le hcc comme
montrer qui est ça vient ça vient pu me
chercher autant et peut-être
inconsciemment oui en fait je pense que
je dise ça me touche pas mais peut-être
qu'inconsciemment ça va me toucher
j'en parle beaucoup avec par exemple je
suis rendu à ses proches et à ses
proches je parle des fois avec le
réalisateur ces femmes par an je sais
pas si vous connaissez si un réalisateur
qui fait dit il fait des documentaires
de tout crin le documentaire la petite
cédrika qui n'est jamais sorti le
châssis et bayard j'ai parlé avec lui en
tout cas pour un projet plus immtel si
ça commence à devenir rofl le ca
commence à jouer sur ma santé mentale et
de tout le temps plongé le système toute
ma vie même si tu t'en as pas content
mais je pense que peut-être que ça vient
de toucher
et puis moi c'est ce diable ça me touche
plus ça me touche plus ça me touche mais
tu es save au touch capable de délits
mais peut-être qu'inconsciemment ça va
me chercher plus que je le pense mais
des fois tu as tu peur que que mettons
les vieilles de bar chez vous juste à
cause de ton hystérique de recherche
interne sérieux les affaires que je
cherche
ouais ouais c'est sûr comme à cacher
encore d'accord
et trafic sexuel en thaïlande sur
youtube ce genre voyez les affaires
jetées non mais c'est pas pour moi je
vous le jure et c'était pour une vidéo
pigeard c'était pour mettre des extraits
vidéos trash suffit aussi que quelqu'un
qui écoute ce ça la rigueur puis papin
comptoir noter si je peux être écoutés
de deux jours de l'asem parfaitement à
paarl clavel auteur mais je sais c'est
celle que je parle il suffit qu'elle lui
une lectrice qui a primé ce sujet qu'est
ce qu'ils écrivaient c'est la
monographie juvénile bomis ramasse
gérard des années de procès là vivent un
cauchemar mourir c'est horrible mettons
que des crimes sordides dit quelqu'un
qui dise on met une tête manquée coûte
ça les excite meetic j'ai tout fait
poteau pour glorifier ce que tu fais
c'est pas parce que tu trouves ça va
mais gallas au 6 mai moi j'écris mitigé
maintenant oui oui mais moi je n'écris
pas jamais là où quand j'avais fait
maintenant que je décris et je voudrais
qu'ils le attention ce que je veux dire
c'est super chacun ouais c'est et je
fais vraiment ni trigger warning mettons
toi tu comprends pas pourquoi quelqu'un
écrire et samatan de la fiction comme se
situe pour ce qui me touche et non et
non je suis vraiment
non non dans le sens que ça c'est dans
ce sens que ses deux enfants de saint
ouen des véhicules mais
je suis vraiment pas d'accord avec le
procès qu est-ce que c'est la fiction le
terrain pendant avait parlé je pense
d'ailleurs avec j'ai testé comme lolita
de nabokov la fiction mais mais en même
temps tout autre débat vous prenant part
au monde bien sûr mais j'avais lu
d'ailleurs c'est quoi la limite de la
fiction parce qu'on n'a jamais vu et je
savais lui le consentement des succès et
le fait un gros sujets le concernant de
vanessa
j'aimerais c'est une fille elle qui est
une française qui elle avait couché avec
un écrivain mais l'os
oui j'ai entendu cette histoire le site
internet est connue la france me
soupçonne qu'ils écrivent ainsi quitus
au dessus c'est un microbe pas reconnu
au puy avait déjà décollé mardi la corde
la bâtisse pied c'est ça le tc quoi
qu'en mai sur la limite de la fiction
parce que mais lui c'était vraiment fond
nous coucher avec juste des démineurs
qui écrivait des très bons romans le
petit st gelais vous mettez que le sim
puis les fictions mais lui ce sont les
laits la liste
la limite est floue qui s'est facilement
justifiable en disant que c'est de la
fiction
ouais ouais mais bon qu'est ce qui est
facile de se cacher derrière le ça
dépend aussi les écrits je dis lui
soumettons il parle de toppi cécifoot
glorifier sefolosha est chez lui menacé
nice et puis mettons mais est ce que tu
es très bons sauts story 5 ans quand
j'ai pas lu puis j'en retire pas une
littérature qui m'intéressent puis c'est
pas quelque chose que tic qui m'attire
nécessairement lesquels mettons la
littérature d'orange amère acquis au
petit matin fax au gpo lui nous je pense
même pas qui est disponible en ce moment
là une série greater mai mais c'est soit
que dans son entrevue puisqu'ils disent
moi j'écris ce
papa pour glorifier sur une équipe all a
dénoncé puis je les décris
il ya des vérités et des vrais êtres
humains qui vivent des horreurs inconnu
ceux qui ont pris ou encore pire pour
n'en parle peu et puis un autre chose
qui est qui et de choses qui a dit
qu'ils étaient quand même pertinente
sidimé ton je pense à un autre un autre
mâle qui parut veulent pas si longtemps
c'était le chien je pense que je peux
t'attendre par des auteurs notre hills
qui raconte comme l'auto fiction en fait
le petit raconte un peu l'enfer qu'elle
a vécu depuis sa décrits vraiment de
façon crue de la pédophilie
inquiet pis ces deux taux fixe et à un
peu son histoire de trafic et mais
jamais personne qui veut crier à fait
juste parce que ce casque note parce qu
un tel sommet parce que je pense quand
même que l'impression que on frime on se
bat sco clairement je trouve que
justement il ya été alors mais ça c'est
classique l'amj d'accord et que l'accord
avec soin mais le point par exemple la
fiction puis de la tête du du de se
cacher derrière le filtre de la fiction
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
vraie c'est maintenant woody allen qui
étiquette pas si lointain peu dans ses
films de genre d'acte écoute manhattan
puis sur -date une fenêtre s'est ainsi
créé beaucoup le même c'est de la
fiction avec louis siquet jean-louis la
masturbation tout le temps après
même des poèmes pour revenir à ton
historique de recherche
dernièrement c'est le moi j'ai jamais
trippé sur le trou cry nécessairement
jamais trompé sur les histoires sordides
pis je comprenais pas la fascination
pour ces choses là même la première fois
qu'on a reçu je comprenais ton succès
par la qualité ton contenu mais je
comprenais pas vraiment la fascination
pour le trou creusé jusqu'à ce que
dernières n'ont pas tag king je suis
tombé moi et mes réalisateurs préférés
c'est david fincher mais je me disais à
barman ça fait longtemps qu'il peut
faire deux films puis j'attendais un
type iphone je fais des films basés sur
des histoires vraies comme zodiac
mettons le clip basé sur le zodiaque qui
se situe sur le site du tout quand même
fiction là mais quand même
puis le je tenais je les vois je ne sais
quoi et l'a remis projet sur lequel il
travaille et puis il ya travaillé et est
producteur exécutif puis il réalisait
quelques épisodes de mind hunter la
série sur netflix
il commence écouter mind hunter pis les
genres comme au début c'est ici ses deux
deux inspecteurs du fbi qui rencontrent
des meurtriers des serial killers puis
au début de rencontre ed kemper qui est
du gameplay
je veux avoir plus d'infos fait lâche
tombe sur google m
kemper le lisseur plaquettes ou telle
personne telle personne écrit le nom de
cette personne n'a dans google je suis
rendu fautes qui nous devons être
déjà sur wikipédia des serrures
pierreuse qui sont inspirés des idées
comme la mythologie derrière ce
meurtrier de masse le tonfa king loin
c'était juste et chrétiens surface que
leur ben moi je t'aime je te donne de
rabais le cliquet des hyperliens
hyperliens utile pour me rendre jusqu'à
jusqu'à une espèce de où est ce que je
voyais plus les meurtriers de masse
comme des meurtriers de masse mais comme
des objets de fascination de comme g et
gecam arrêté j'ai fait cette personne le
qui est en train de m'informer beaucoup
il est connu pour avoir tué huit
étudiantes dans un sur un campus aux
états unis les genres pis il a décapité
puis fori leurs coûts mais ton c'est
déjà le match le plus juste en train de
deux comme parents c'est intéressant à
148 de cuisine
après cela j'ai continué à écouter la
série qui que moi je très plat j'ai pas
fini il reste deux épisodes mais comme
j'ai capote sur cet îlot de type i
pilote voile est le personnage cruel
kempen comme sa petite moustache y
grimper gens s'expriment super bien un
club tu lippi sait exactement sur pile
après six rencontres charles manson pu
rencontrer
le west end finir le set sur le pilote
j'ai comme j'ai comme compris il y
compris qu est ce qui pouvait devenir
fascinant dans ce mais cette
compréhension la lpo venu sans une
espèce de petit culpabilité on dirait de
ma part de faire
on dirait que j'accorde beaucoup
d'importance à quelque chose qui
vraiment décollé samedi puis kelly
sûrement que toi tu réfléchis beaucoup
plus longuement cette question là puis
je vais te l'a posée parce que moi je
suis pas capable de mettre le doigt sur
quelle est ma quelle est la limite que
je devrais m'imposer à ma fascination
pour des actes comme sur le même ton est
ce que c'est quelque chose à laquelle je
réfléchis j'ai fait une longue
parenthèse pour arriver à une gestion
qui en ce moment je suis là dedans parce
que j'étais en train d'écouter assez
riche capote sa série mais je me dis
qu'ils risquent il ya quelque chose qui
me dérange le dans les faits que je
capote sur les sujets de la série ben ça
c'est fou parce que tout le monde me le
demande parce que leur aventure quand
même vraiment la mode du let flex est
toutes les sonnettes est si belle le
mois - les trans et moi mon truc
chevalet disparition peuvent être liés à
une personne qui agit en solo et à une
répétition parfois ou non oui ça en
effet et puis j'en parlais avec mon père
qui m'a dit c'est ce que pose pas la
question c'est quand il ya un accident
sur le bord de la route pourquoi tout le
monde râle ans
pourquoi tu as l'impression de
l'accident et dans ta voix alors que
c'est de l'autre côté de l'eau
pourquoi tu ralentis la fascination peau
si je sors ce comportement humain s'est
enfoncée
c'est la fascination mais j'étais chez
est-ce que ça prendrait comme un
psychiatre ou un psychologue qui
pourrait nous expliquer ça c'est une
curiosité morbide la limite à m je sais
pas c'est toi qui va être là m et
pourquoi tu dois être une lumière
ça peut partir de quelque chose de plus
profond le toit le ticket pourquoi cette
fascination là tu es toi ce que tu lé la
panique chez les moins mitigé coûté la
série si je suis un fan est intéressant
surtout l'espèce de titres parce
qu'avant je pense que point le on
n'avait jamais aussi de comprendre qu
est ce qui a amené quelqu'un s'est basé
sur un livre qui s'est vraiment passé
sur des gars qui ont vraiment fait seuls
les termes c'est là que ça vient de là
mettez c'est le moins que toi peut-être
ben moi parce que je suis frais dans le
team c'est comme je peux pas décroché de
l'ordinateur quand j'écoute la série les
tunnels et je les fais tu fait la même
affaire que tout car les cristallise
wikipedia le plus intéressant mais skip
woods
ces quatre là la fascination la
curiosité devient de l'admiration de
prison que joyon des lions des cultes
qu'il ya des gens qui sont en amour avec
si quelqu un député ça va pas cesser un
trouble de personnes moi mais il ya un
an et on se mettait pas mon mari 16h le
lui ça l'intéresse pas en tout genre
c'est vraiment utile de personnalités
moi ça m'attire mais peu ça m'attire
mais pas pareil moi c'est comme le s'est
rendu c'est une passion mais c'est
entendu quelque chose donc le mot c'est
comme un rendu à un désir d'aider ces
camps différents ne sais plus ouais
ouais mais ça reste ça ça reste étrange
me pose la question puis je voudrais pas
possiblement qu'après ces mots je me
rappelle avoir écouté zodiac avoir
capoté sur le film du genre à vous
retrouver sur votre kit bond puis après
ça tu sais les films qui ont marqué mon
imaginaire le seven c'est sans aucun
doute un des films qui m'a le plus
marqué depuis seven si ce n'est ce pas
tu sais pas c'est pas excessif
fictionnel mais c'est des comportements
de 2
meurtrier en série qui existent le titre
comme un film d'horreur
c'est peut-être peut-être un besoin de
sensations fortes genre de thriller que
c'est plus sûr ouais et moi je pense moi
c'était surtout ça c'était quand même
besoin de sensations fortes c'est comme
dit comme les montagnes russes qui
menaient les fans d'horreur mais
satisfaisait plus vraiment fait que je
me suis tourné vers le trou quand même
parce que le stéréo
j'avais besoin dans le plus fort encore
mais penses tu que justement le fait que
les humains ont une fascination pour ce
ça pousse certaines personnes à
commettre des actes parce que sa voix
l'iran tallec ou savent où ils vont
attirer cette espèce de fascination le
bien-être su que mettons dans des locaux
qui connaît que le désir c'était le
cadre comme agneau talent lui que je
pense oui en est surtout plus récemment
avec les médias sociaux ont souvent tu
es live louey
parce que ceux ci sont l'avait poste
espèce de curiosité loeb c'était
justement le plaisir morbide de checker
ce ca ca découragerait pas de certaines
personnes que c'est ce qu'ils
recherchent
oui mais ouais ouais ça serait aussi
d'épaulé ouais mais des polynômes et
chez qui est fils de frank hoj pas si
vous suivez sur youtube elle soit
youtube art que j'aime beaucoup qui
parle qui raconte les nouvelles puis lui
ce qu'il fait quand il ya des tueries
justement il nomme paul du même genre
mais on la remarque maintenant je pense
qu'un caddie tragédie on veut plutôt
focus est surnommé les victimes parlent
des victimes de parler juste 2 et c'est
quoi qu'on peut métier je sais pas si je
sais pas si c'est il y en a tellement
qui veulent utiliser l'histoire ils vont
tuer par désir de tripes mais pas par
désir d'être célèbre y en a pas
énormément et je pense que c'est sa part
d'un trouble de santé mentale souvent ou
est ce un point c'est un trouble de
santé mentale mais c'est pas
nécessairement par désir de la tnt le
corps comme en utah où il y avait il
voulait être célèbres mais avec quelque
chose à la base avec sursis ne s'étaient
pas juste avec le maintenant maintenant
c'est vraiment le désir de
dès qu'ils pousseront ce n'est pas ce
qui m'est en jeu parce que je pense que
tous déjà posé question de la messe qui
aimait tant ce que tu es ce que tu as le
sentiment qui contribue justement faire
avancer les ddd cause des recherches des
enquêtes
c'est tellement difficile comme je suis
allé samedi deux semaines schalit il y
avait des fouilles pour 1000 sable et
j'ai mis sur un 50 pieds et j'ai
rencontré la famille pitt the tellers
puis j'ai vu et sa belle à belfort 2005
c'est celle qui est vraiment comme en
charge mais c'est la porte parole de la
famille parce que bon je pense que
certaines distances et le canton de
centre et sylvie qui a sapé comme jeudi
vers 8 l'ap
on sait comme vu de loin de là s'est mis
à pleurer mais on peut être pas se poser
que le tri g par rapport l'aïe ou buzz
qu'est ce que je fais le plus jeter
c'est pas mal à l'aise d'être vraiment
pas contente du choix le plateau lorrain
on dit mais victoria merci merci
tellement d'être le petit merci pour
tout ce que tu fais jeter ça m'a
tellement soulagé bien dit et je reçois
des messages la belgique et de la france
puis genre ça me fait vraiment ça me
fait vraiment plaisir puis elle dit dans
le fond les fecteau on parle ça leur
donne espoir que si on continue le tcc
on oublie paul on oublie peuple c'est
juste de donner comme j'étais de la
visibilité puis j'ai dit tout le temps
c'est de la visibilité
mais oui ça leur fait vraiment plaisir
puis juste la salle basse belge avant
hier le je reçois un message
le frère de diane carier le scientifique
qui a disparu ça fait super longtemps à
montréal mais encore le sait ça fait
quand même plus de vingt ans plus de
trente habile veux tu en parles sur
youtube c'est fait je suis souvent en
contact avec les familles je pense que
c'est ma manière de dire oui parce que
c'est des disparitions à celle des
vieilles disparition bien d'en parler
d'en parler de continuer d'en parler
mais je pense ça donne espoir aux
familles fait que j'avais pas
concrètement tu sais je suis pas là à
fouiller ya cru mais genre
c'est une manière puis quel pourcentage
des dca que tu traites qui sont qu'ils
sont encore actifs que c'est pas des coq
est calqué sur ceux qui ferment ça veut
dire qu'ils quitteraient glace parce que
nice 13 juillet comme on a on a plus de
l'inapi lépi puis je m'adonne quart
d'heure qui sont résolus puis tu fais
juste raconter l'histoire ou août est
mieux qu'un qui sait où va pourcentage
et je sais pas mais maintenant il y en a
que tu fait qu'ils sont encore actifs le
pic et pic y aura encore des évidences
qui pourrait ressortir ps que ça tu es
tu arrivé d'avoir des messages à ses
crédits pour intervenir auprès des
inspecteurs auprès des personnes en
charge du dk ce que je veux dire tu
rejoins définitivement plus de monde que
l'inspecteur qui va aller de porte à
porte pour s'informer maintien oui sauf
que tu dois te recevoir aussi une chute
tonnes de messages qui sont vraiment pas
crédible du fait des atrides way et bien
que je vous en ai raconté comme ça
touche pas trop en parler mais oui et
j'en ai comme 2,3 récemment mais triste
aux lignes je ne peux pas parler mais tj
reçus de quoi qui celui là puis chez que
la police avait déjà rencontré la
personne en soi qui avait été éliminé
que comme suspecte le savent est à moi
en parler peut-être la famille qu est ce
que tu es sont immergés de messages de
demande qui se mange pas dans ce cas
c'est le passé ni comme étant le ticket
du monde y ont pensé
c'est surtout dans les commentaires de
la vidéo que d'ailleurs les commentaires
je regarde plus autant bien ouais même
youtube studios fox fois que ça arrive
quand tient pas compte mais tout est
déjà été en contact avec la police dire
et dansant sinon non
non qu'ils aient dans des futurs projets
sera sûrement à voir mais pour mes
vidéos this 600 photos les policiers de
ce que je fais je ne vais pas m'étendre
mettons que de tous appris quelque chose
par la banque qui aimait tant les autres
avaient pu livrer le savons plus ce que
tu sais mettons nous à pau pour l'aide
au network lequel est un organisme à
part je fais pour des recherches pour
des personnes disparues le oui parce que
pour vérifier des nôtres à former des jo
puis de djendel des personnes tatouées
sens d'identité des fois je fais des
matches denses que est-ce que telle
personne retrouvée serait-elle meerson
disparu le fou qu'on vérifie fait que
l'on est en contact avec les policiers
mais ça c'est encore indiqué puis est ce
que tu es j'imagine que tu peux pas
rentrer dans spéculation l'outil en
ligne peut pas dire la vidéo et moi je
pense que c'est lui qui l'a fait
non mais moi je peux dire et je suis
prêt mais ce serait vraiment vraiment
attention à ce que je sais moi je pense
mémoire ita trentaine qui est pas une
professionnelle je peux dire que c'est
assez louche cette affaire leur métier
c'est vraiment selon moi vite c'est
celle qui aurait pu ce curieux qu'on a
pas justement de des commentaires
qu'elle sur soi parce que temps en temps
je vois que tu aimais tant tu prends les
pires pis métairie mais de l'air d'avoir
mais je pense prince team et ont
majoritairement été d'avoir une idée un
des abonnés suivent qui t'aiment picchi
qui il chante aunis son drama le youtube
c'est joli sur twitter c'est commencer
c'est gros ben c'est roger j'arrête pas
de voir passer mais pas si ce terme là
c'est partout mais qui sont vraiment
fans qui justement qui viennent
ouais t4 n'importe où y est toujours de
mon choix mais tu as l'impression que tu
es aussi du drôle d'amont qui toi qui
tuent et mutilent le sujet attire ouais
je sais pas comment le décrire
mais mettons commente qu'embrasse cul
parce que j'ose ouais ouais
puis comment tu expliques ça m'aide
t'avais dis jamais on peut parler d'être
kat von d parfois on pourrait parler
exactement de tig et on peut parler
s'écouter gosse mais tenter d'en dans
dans ce genre de commentaires que tu
peux recevoir parce que j'ai vu que des
fois mettons si je pense que tu essaies
de faire les choses avec les plus grand
respect qu'il est petit ouais ça se paie
au dessus des fois mettons désabonner ça
soit ça soit pas sous le même temps il
ya un genre de mark ii comme quelque
chose qui se perd ferait peser comme
parle de oui oui oui c'est par exemple
les deux et les enfants aient les deux
petites filles qui étaient quittés
kidnappé le par leur père louis
carpentier voilà et c'est genre iphone
vidéo sur seulles
c'était dans l'air on les cherche encore
nice ça fait une heure sont portées
disparues
on vient de recevoir la lettre par l'irt
ambert puy qu'est ce que tu peux
apporter de plus que lille nouvelle sas
normal que ça arrive le rythme et même
même là je vois pas d'en parler dans un
an j'en parlerai pas parce que ces mêmes
guy turcotte j'ai pas envie d'en parler
cette affaire là parce que je trouve ses
troupes que c'est irrespectueux je
trouve que ses yeux il n'y a pas de
mystère il ya pas d je vois pas ce que
je parle nice est toujours dramatique
en fait toute liste l'histoire dont je
parle c'est dramatique métiers saas et
comme je dois pour traiter une personne
en faisant ce nom c'est exact c'est
comme
est-ce que se sentir mal deux mettons
capitaliser sur jeu tout est tout à fait
légal afin de capitaliser sur des drames
non parce que je n'en n'ont pas
nécessairement parce que si je raconte
une histoire dans le respect petit jeu
peut souvent mini pc tout étant aidé à
trouver des tissus des témoins un ami ou
autrement mais seuls si c'est ça je
trouve que des fois c'est trop vieille
route ses défauts tu peux te parler de
cette histoire
maire depuis gens qui mettent des mots
j'ai aimé c'est quand on a beaucoup des
très jeunes qui me suit postes soit aidé
dans mon lit séance de dédicaces y avait
des petites filles de 8 9 ans qui menait
world bon c'est ça ça reste aux parents
jugés s'ils veulent que leurs enfants me
regarde
mais fx et soyez peut-être qu'ils
comprennent pas la gravité des choses ne
faut pas oublier qu'ils étaient ici
c'est pour justement de la fiction star
avait dit vrai ou si elles ont des
familles qui existe pour vrai c'est ce
que est ce que des fois tout
l'impression que tu perds 7e cette
nuance le mettons à force d'en voir des
cas même puis de commencer à traiter sur
plus comme des des dossiers accusé
vraiment des humains qui sont disparus
des familles dans le deuil et puis tout
seul
non ça dépend je fais quand même
attention quand c'est des cas est
français québécois belges âgés rien
caché qu'il y avait des gens qui vont
les voitures la famille des amis et je
fais vraiment vraiment attention
souvent je vais essayer jamais me
contacter les familles avant d'en parler
mais comme eric un très médiatisé mais
c'est plus à lyon sans guillemets et
c'est par exemple au jay simpson si je
savais que je pouvais rien à me revoir
le messie jeté la bombe c'est un
cocktail mancel m que ça me dérange pas
d'en parler dans la dernière année c'est
quoi le c'est quoi le cas qui te le plus
qui te plus intéressé monde il y en a
tellement mais mettons en tête comme que
tu y penses et le samedi et attend une
ontarienne et qui disparut tâche était
binger foule était en contact avec sa
famille et alpes et en 2020 elle avait
comme deep run le sentimental mais on
savait pas en fait
mais on pense et était quand même à
penser qu'il avait des caméras dans son
appartement ce fait de 27,1 delphi a
fait ses jardins des chaudes stand-up à
chanter dans les bars belle-fille mais
on s'en fout qu'il soit belle en fait un
grand potentiel faisait de la lutte il
faudra toucher à tout pire que juste
comme sortie de chez elle avec un sac de
vidanges on la voit six caméras sacs de
vidanges vraiment mort et peep le ratio
tier 1 s'est pas bien le juste comme
disparues comme ça et le lendemain sont
ses parents sont arrivés
et puis on sera là y'a pas porté disparu
puis genre dix jours après on la voit
bien on n'a pas marché on la banque ans
et cameron aurait ans pour l'avoir
marché a coûté sa propre affiche de
disparition c'est vraiment faut qu'ils
ses parents il a cherché beaucoup
puissent entrer en contact avec eux et
ils m'ont vraiment j'ai fait une vidéo
opté par envoyer comme j'ai dit je leur
ai posé des questions vous m'en voyez
comme une vidéo d'eux qu'ils répondent à
mes questions pendant 45 minutes
lotissement millions vraiment comme été
généreux de leur temps mais c'est aussi
ça les arrangeait pas ce qu'il disait ça
se pourrait vraiment qu'elle soit à
montréal tu es au canada et je voudrais
pas c'est facile
de se déplacer puis mais ma communauté
ont vraiment cherché aussi puis à l'eiti
retrouvée morte et reste comme un mois
le fait que dans quelles conditions on
mais on sait pas on sait pas encore mais
dans l'eau dans un genre où hamilton en
ontario dans l'eau on sait pas question
mais je pense que c'est peut-être un
suicide mais tu apportes n'était pas
dépressif ni quoi que ce soit fait tête
c'est un accident si le tac et ongles la
dernière fois qu'elle a été vue c'était
bien que le marché
côté sa part qu'un séjour après être
disparue oui mais en six ans on pense
qu'ils étaient peut-être pas là durant
disparaître aussi à l'appli sa famille
en pleurant piazze genre est quelqu'un
qui me chassait dans les bois georges
étayer des gueux qui me court après d'un
bois par exemple quand même être un
psycho cheka fumait beaucoup beaucoup de
weeds fait que ça peut causer à ses
côtés déjà du fait que cela va vraiment
touché parce que je peux lui et comme je
connaissais mais j'avais parlé à sa
famille que les mettons la question
manhunters un mémorable de séquelles
meurtrier en série qui dit je pense que
je les applique déjà il doit doit avoir
20 ces serial killeuse aux états unis
s'est plaint l'autre répond et 10/20 que
vous êtes au courant c'est parce que les
meilleurs vous le savez pas ce qu'ils
font sur le mieux vous le savez pas quel
est selon toi
puis selon les histoires qui sont comme
sans dénouement pic des qui sait comme
mieux pas vraiment d'explication ne
serait-ce que l'intervention d'une
tierce personne
quels sont selon toi le pourcentage des
coques de disparition non résolue qui
sont de l'umih les fameux pourcentage en
20 %
nestea mais peut-être est-ce que tu
penses que c'est plus souvent
qu'autrement qu'est cbi meurtre mais qui
sait quelqu'un d'autre qui est qui qui
est intervenu ou que c'est juste une
disparition de quelqu'un mais tant qu'il
ya des troubles de santé mentale qui
s'est perdu ou qui est tombé évanoui au
quai des bulles et des hommes s'est
soigné des je pense que c'est souvent
des suicides
quand les hommes les hommes disparus
c'est pas sonné suicide
mon dieu c'est tellement compliqué des
jeunes femmes ça va être plus des moeurs
qui et quand c'est des femmes qui
disparaissent à des prix tellement bas
que c'est en bonne voie et temps des
jeunes filles ça doit des fugues c'est
sa dépendance mais des soirs en syrie là
il y en a pas tant que ça paris -
sûrement sur mon jeu c'est pas pour ça
l'institution qui est qu'il y en a tant
que ces seuils en a pas tant que ça
dépit des des disparitions au québec
l'autre ici on a ausculté
mais on n'en a pas tant que soit lancée
par pitié mettant justement quand
t'écoutes d'or de série de même quand tu
es quand s'intéresse à cette rencontre
souvent mettons un tueur en série va
voir un patin nothing une méthode de
travail que le tibet reconnaîtra qui
s'est clairement même personne parce
qu'ils dessinent qui fait qu'il ait agi
de la même façon
est-ce que met-on en ce moment il ya
billy remettons des caisses que genre
qui arrive teddy qui clairement c'est
lié à la personne indiquée présence de
chercher là dessus il est d'ailleurs
hier et autres chutes dans le il y en a
dans les années enfin des années 80 à
montréal il y en avait plus l'air
marrant c'est qu'il
parce que comme une affaire de huit neuf
jeunes filles de 16 et 17 ans qui ont
été assassinés c'étaient des jeunes
filles qui disparaissait mais c'était
tout un endroit il y en eut un mur à
laval longueuil montréal drummondville
puis c'est tout dans les comtés
différents dans le fond fake
pis les policiers à cette époque
je parlais je parlé au réalisateur
stéphane parent justement il racontait
que à cette époque les policiers
parlaient pas vraiment entre eux c'était
tous des cons des corps de police ont
effectué par les personnes se transférer
l'information comme une cape a vraiment
ruffec pour le temps si système
américain en syrie
y at-il eu des ajustements à ces
endroits le pit et c'était facile pour
lui le sens sortie contre si on parle
d'un tueur en série fait qu'ils aient eu
énormément énormément avec sept huit
meurtres qui paie pour ça endort 75 et
80 à montréal j'étais quoi le
dénominateur commun à toutes ces caisses
et différée des jeunes filles de 16 et
20 ans ne trouvait jamais où elle est
retrouvée morte en charente 2 deux jours
et deux mois environ
plus tard devenu un viol et viol y être
anglais au frappé à la tête et les les
8,10 par action est de retrouver
éventuellement qui est à 1,6 on les
retrouvait total en bordure d'une
autoroute ou dans un boisé fait que ça
s'arrête là lourd que ce soit un tueur
en série puis aussi j'ai remarqué fait
que c'est une affaire puis jean-marc
juste pour klose et ça n'a jamais été
résolu non aucun suspect aucun rythme
non parce que jarre as tes potes lot il
y avait pas vraiment des technologies en
matière dans des épreuves qui se sont
perdues détruits par les policiers
c'était vraiment mal faible je suis en
train d'investiguer sur le mur de johan
dorion en particulier juste la scène de
crime ça le ferait elle a été poignardée
genre tellement de fois jean nouveau du
pubis qu'on n'est même pas capable de
voir si elle était bien lire en plus
tellement dedans que je les raconte
parce que ça fait genre une semaine
mais avec sa famille elle s'est prise
parce que c'est lorsque son plusieurs
frères et soeurs plus ils essaient
encore de trouver ça fait sept ans 77
puis 2020 ils sont encore en train de
chercher qui est fait comme ça c'est un
bon copain au dessus communiqué que la
famille ouais ça sert colette dorion
hilali crédible en fonds pour ok mais
pour com mais pour on va essayer de
mettre la lumière soit elle avait juste
17 ans et c'est toute la vie devant elle
puisque moi c'est ça est ce que l'étude
et moment contacter la famille qui
veulent rien savoir qu'il dise on vous
pas que ce qui est quand même étonnant
c'est que ça arrive souvent oui c'est
étonnant parce que j'te lorsque je
comprends le métier je t'offre du
quasiment 500 milles non mais c'est pas
tout mais vidéo comme 500000 vue mais
geof du minimum 300 mille bulles 300000
personnes qui vont être au courant dit
enfin le 300000 personnes je me faisais
que des fois mes tantes et un enfant
même des fois tu veux juste passer à
autre chose je suis tombé dans ce que tu
en as non mais la plupart ils veulent
nom de la plupart sont le par les entier
et oui il se pose c'est du monde qu'ils
veulent je sais qu'ils veulent la
visibilité
j'ai pas de membres qui veulent passer à
autre chose dans leur ville
pascal mettons ces comportements le jeu
pourrait le comprendre et admettons le
tour seulement une quinzaine de familles
s'apprend
rahmani tu dire qu'il faut que je fasse
la paix avec ses hobbies je fais aussi
là dans ma tête que je n'en parle pas
tant parlé notamment de thé de quelqu'un
qui devient quelqu'un et on en reparle
qu'on retrouve le 15 finale ana ça se
peut que s'attendre maintenant je
comprends non si tu manques sont un
média qui avec l'âge facebook pour
retrouver et non c'est arrivé maintenant
si cette fois le quai je contacter la
famille veulent pas parce que tu pourras
plus personnelle parce que tu dis qu'ils
n'ont pas confiance à ce que je peux
apporter
whaou qui qui sans qu'ils comprennent
que youtube
ok moi parce que je suis un petit tube
accessory kiki qui vont les coins de
sérieux de la démarche
ouais c est arrivé deux fois avec des
québécois mais c'est surtout des
français
une fois c'était je suis parce que ils y
ont dit oui
si j'avais écrit comme mon script pour
la vidéo mais je disputais san algériens
ont fait leur entrée dans les détails
pied il y avait ce problème qui
coûteront peu mais je vais pas dire le
nom mais il était une bisexuelle mais si
il sortait avec une femme trans puis moi
j'étais en contact avec sa copine de la
personne disparue et puis je l'avais dit
le dans les dents mon script et puis sa
famille dit non lyon body enlève ce type
je pense que je leur ai envie ça
m'aurait pas dérangé si je veux vraiment
respecté la famille mais en dix ans dans
votre poursuivre ce genre de scènes
vidéo j'étais là je veux juste aider à
le retrouver
je veux pas me faire poursuit vallet à
reparler d'un autre ouais mais c'est
juste à l'est ville levis énormément
disparition leur importance du genre la
fin de trente disparition dans le
secteur de lévis oui mais mais je
pensais que parce que c'est le pont qui
le fait que ça se peut que ça sonne en
même temps disparition depuis mettons
west ham à 30 90 et aujourd'hui
beaucoup la même temps puis l'estomac le
fleuve les chances que tu retrouves le
cas du courant pensez quoi
ou est ce que le corps fini je sais pas
ce qu'ils font est quelqu'un qui vient
chercher jusqu'à temps qu'ils trouvent
ou mais ils font des fouilles mais je
sais pas ils repêchent souvent les corps
qui sont maharaja 3g comme le métro mais
ce qui me gêne c'est paris qui retrouve
jamais piqué le 15 mai puis tu te parler
de déco france et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de thé écoute qui proviennent
de l'ue
ouais ça c'est pour ça c'est quand même
honteux et view était vu comme ne le dit
pas mais j'écoute audio/vidéo ces
écoutes
j'en reviens encore la question des
commentaires parce que ça me fait quand
même vraiment rire mais oui et montre
comment les accents et partager
c'est très calme
ouais mais c'est parce que je sais c'est
juste parce que manger les reçu la
notification parce que comme je dis gir
4 mai mais tu penses tu que ces grandes
écoles isolées ou bailleurs gens
vraiment une espèce de d'attitude
généralisée envers les québécois que
comme il parle un français est inférieur
aux attentes mais le jir suscite assez
j'ai reçu plein de commentaires gens
sont installés mais non on aime vraiment
l'accent québécois
je pense que c'est quand même vrai parce
que tout cas maintenant quand j'ai été
reçue dans sur les plateaux le genre en
france
tout le monde disait que j'avais
vraiment un bel axe sécu et puis même
dans les restos en france mais chez vous
vous êtes déjà à lille genre les gens
sont vraiment gentils cité avec l accent
canadien avant les gens aiment quand
même l'accent québécois
mais si j'ai travaillé et au mexique
j'ai travaillé avec des france cgt prof
de français puis on n'a jamais dit
collègues français oui mais sont surtout
des peut-être des profs de français ou
là que le processus
oui mais je sais c'est extrêmement
condescendant tout le temps tout le
temps mais j'ai juste des petits trucs
je te dis quoi jean salsa salsa dispose
pas de français mais je sais c'est alors
que c'est quand tu côtoies du front des
français comme tout le temps le thé ça
va ça va des petits commentaires qui on
dire que ces gens un peu condescendant
mais en plus selon selon les linguistes
parler le français
universitaire québécois c'est comme le
français le plus notre culture ouais
ouais ouais faut que j'aille le français
qui est parlée dans les sphères
universitaires donc un bon français par
les québécois si le français bruno
croquet fait qu techniquement les
français y ont un accent ou si c'est
vrai c'est cependant eu 30
petit mettant la destruction avec mon
cousin qui est linguiste le mans tpiy
c'est parce qu'à man et les langues
existantes les langues évoluent
dépendamment des réalités des régions
pour ceux qui sont juste comme se pisser
juste intéressant de pourquoi concernés
par le même pourquoi te colle pas le
domaine pu trouver ce boom était
apprécié de dire non il ya la bonne
manière de parler par m pas des débats
comme aucun sens c'est genre les
commentaires c'est une chose mais
surtout mettez pas sur twitter mais toi
tu es sur twitter mais ça fait pas
longtemps leur jeu ça fait longtemps
mais je suis vraiment actif le médoc
gens qui partagent vos clubs français
parce que ils partagent des tic toc de
québécois puisse à byron bay rôle de
michael jackson ouais ou jamais jean
rochefort un tweet au mérite whitlock
giacomelli québécois mais font mourir
jean rapinât pas de sens fais-toi
dimanche passé avait coûté aux des
extraits là après les après haut débit
et des dessins et aux
îles-de-la-madeleine y fait des cages de
pour capturer les clémentines pilote il
ya un axe est vraiment fort king for
l'église et la madeleine on tue le tue
reconnaît l'édile axa puis j'ai fait
genre et vous avez un axe un plugin
regard fait pour moi qu'un accueil c'est
tout cas la dgi fait vous avez raison on
dit chez vous ici c'est moi qui auront
accès délégué d'axa europe annoncé mais
c'est comme ses autres petits symboles
c'est la diversité du langage plus on se
comprend quand l'accent des usa sous
genre pêcheurs de homard mais le
guerrier son accent était épaisse
thomas kohler pas comment il s'appelle
médias les muqueuses gt coupé les
métiers à limite jusque pas raciste le
t6 gentil je prenais une certaine région
j'y aille au congo il dit sol
pour claude glossophonie non mérité en
pour ce sport racisme et c'est ce qu'ils
vont mourir de la langue pose en victime
mais sega fêté après ce mois je pense
que tu perds pas ton accent j'étais vous
je pense que c'est préférable de votes
exprimés pis tu es des méthodes de
pouvoir vraiment exprimer sa pensée de
la façon la plus claire et la plus dans
toutes ses nuances possibles loterie
fait qu'après ce site un répertoire de
quatre mots pour parler tu es plus
limitée que tu parlais justement un
français qui mais après sur l'accent
jeudi écrit c'est fred pellerin la
personne qui on va te conter une
histoire peut-être le plus pendu à ses
lèvres ça va être les plus caloriques
toi + moi dix mots il ya un accent gros
comme une offre perdre un chemin qui
s'envole c'est quelqu'un qui parle de
ses shows qui fait en france
je garde le même axe un méchant shirt
une petite affaire c'est comme des tic
tac la rebatte gbagbo n'est pas que ce
soit la rebaptise tactile change le
bonbon pour un bonbon france elle
comprend ya manifestement une nouvelle
qui contestaient piste et 3,4 marie
dessous le ticket d'or pour le sérieuses
plaies et écrans piste école compte et
qui étayé beau resto et en france c'est
comme dans du beurre te plaît du coin du
bar filet il dit moi je dois dire du
barca tant qu'imam end pas un guerrier
c'est
enlevez gratton semaine à wickham ans et
j'apprends matos pittsburgh du quoi je
barre de sécurité sous forte hausse en
france si de la marque vous trémousser
la génération les simpson ne dit que tu
sais quand j'étais jeune superman ita
aux marketeurs dans un resto chic c'est
comme le prendriez been des lentilles
[Rires]
c'est une mère de traduction des
opinions même des références culturelles
québécoises le jardin des mots il fait
un espace led piperz garde j'ai l'air de
charles lafortune référence québécois
comme péter simpson en langue régionale
c'est comme s'ils se pose pas vers une
société qu on voulait on veut parler
avec toi
de g j'ai vu ou que ça juste avait
enlevé des vidéos tâche louis des vidéos
de conspiration de taschen parce que
comme on en a déjà parlé quand est venu
maintenant commencé avec ce peu de la
conspiration et tous puis puis la
dernière mode de jeu se retirer des
vidéos ta chambre
c'est quoi le c'est quoi ton thinking
par rapport à tout ce dont on entend
aussi vent tourne sans arrêt parlé un
petit peu la première fois que j'ai vu
mais définitivement dans la dernière
année le phénomène la conspiration plus
problématique que ça amène celle
exploser le sida vraiment le fait
qu'elle était jean king dans toute cette
séquence d'événements le bec c'est plus
pareil le lot témoin j'ai commencé et
voilà j'ai commencé à la chaîne dos ces
deux semaines mais oui comment
christophe c'est pas pareil de faire une
vidéo genre beyoncé est ce que les
illuminati du genre est ce que l'homme a
marché sur la lune pour de vrai
oui ou non à la ça peut te suit devant
le tribunal et de consulter jacques et
chez sa copine monde ça peut aussi
justifier un espèce de climat de doutes
envers les politiques sociales
immédiates mais tpiy
puis je n'ai pas que j'ai il ya quand
même des parce que c'est poche parce que
les théories de complots j'ai
l'impression que petit peu pu être oui
vous partagez ces cinq hommes qui ne
nous a même pas venir
white est peu plus douter des trucs peu
plus parce que c'est soit tu t'es
conspirationnistes soit sur l'épaule
sont un mouton ouais c'est ça un mouton
ou illuminé et fait clair j'ai commencé
par mettre le j'avais vu c'était quand
même un article 2
patrick lagacé surpise gates tout ça
j'ai passé lui qui n'avait que 5 et moi
j'ai comme plus en face aussi aux gens
qui croque the gate qu'il en avait parlé
en plus je pense sur notre dernier
podcast avec j'ai dû me en privé cette
vidéo peut tout le monde écrivent ils
étaient huit à dix belges pensent que je
vais la mettre en privé pour un certain
temps puis je vois la m public après
après tout tout ce mouvement là des
antilles masse capitaux on s'en reparle
puis après j'ai dit c'est quoi je pense
que je vais être muette mettre mes
vidéos conspirationnistes j'en ai gardé
une ses jardins est-ce que l'aéroport de
denver
c'est quoi la conséquence c'est contrôlé
par le new growth ça dérange personne
c'est juste ça encore la cdu
divertissante et si je me prends pas au
sérieux et elle était médecin de ton
point de vue c'est un métier par les
cheveux que j'en parle maintenant j'y
crois pas vive notre exposé les faits s
c'est la théorie parce que toutes ces
théories sont juste en anglais puis je
légiste comme les traduire en français
possesseurs dit je mets de la musique et
par an je les ai comme milan et je les
ai mis en privé pour un certain temps
mais je sais plus pense pour les
remettre en public et publics pour
l'instant mais c'est ça je trouve que ça
c'est plus le fun ça le prix notre
tourneur
parce que ce qui est donné glad la
visibilité de la force mais ton
mouvement qui donne ces genres de
youtube en cliquant non par les tic au
début c'était comme ce terrain marginale
parce que quelle influence a maintenant
une bonne question que j'ai lu les
articles puisque c'est ce côté fillette
de 10 ans qui est venu ici métier a en
réalité je sais pas qui parce que si on
jette un oeil sur internet and i'm happy
que ça arrivera m'a aidée par un truc
mais tu sais pas ce que c'est
effectivement on aurait dit celle qui
sait il faisait référence à qui paraît
au dessus mais c'est parce que je peux
facilement avoir c'est parce que dans le
fond le mouvement qui au nom des fils
qui nous expliquait sur forte chaîne
programme vraiment obscures
puis ce qui a fait que ça le transférait
de obscures a compris cette information
là qu'il y avait une autre histoire
meanstream qui l'ont amené à l'extérieur
alex jones puis j'ai aucune idée youtube
demain je pense pas que ça soit des
youtuber non je pense pas que ce soit
yann daboul je pense que non mais oui
mais alex jones je pensais bien youtube
ouais ouais je m'attends le
problématique ou non m
c'est qui l'agent mais au début c'est
lui il ya quand même et infiltrer une
cérémonie de ce collège bomb genre je
connais pas son oeuvre instance était
bienveillant au départ j'ai fait je vais
mouiller ce que sa démarche de son point
de vue et bienveillante le piquet way
qui se considère comme étant une espèce
de fruits speech puis des fuites un king
pin en attendant la main mais après
c'est quand y tenait à avancer que
certaines tueries temps est un hoax ou
qu'est aussi seul ça fait quand même
puissance moi je dirais que sur youtube
à la stèle et sa popularité était meti a
été je pense était un des premiers et
baning et youtube
cueillez sur quatre plateformes il
continue à faire sa part je sais pas de
casse et puis je sais pas qu'est ce qui
fait à ce qu'ils auraient fait genre le
podcast le plus long de l'histoire de
joe rogan de genre 5ème ou est ce que
c'est juste lui qui comme c'est que de
l'air complètement possédée eu le
pichoux de la conspiration pendant cinq
heures de temps mais dans le fond luis
escobar bond ces gens là la société
secrète de deuil et puis avait bouche de
danse george bush et
puis apparemment il dansait dans les
rituels d'initiation lille aujourd'hui
séance de masturbation qui te le dis si
vraiment ça sonne comme les remparts de
québec
ah oui mais tout les yeux quand même
vraiment du monde important sur gazon
wikipédia relative aux joutes des
signaux de grosses compagnies les clubs
pour la santé coûte
sauf qu ils sont d'inite inpi un stage
et le site
en fait on sait pas vraiment ce qui se
passe parce que c'est sur une île le
type s'il faut la foule sacrés genre
mais personne tu peux aller leurs
enfants sauf les membres qui est alex
jones
il réussit à aller le pied a filmé puis
tu entends des cris puis en fait c'est
sur youtube
c'est vraiment phoques et là c'est
vraiment ça qui est fait que si je
pensais que le populaire et tamar mac
puis mais parce que ces affaires là
c'est sûr que ça existe beaucoup plus qu
on pense là mais c'est ce que demain
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai pas la
difficulté à croire certaines théories
de complot parce que c'est quand même
fort king les gens super importante qui
contrôle un peu le monde parce que si
tous d'ici aux deux des plus grosses
compagnies
c'est juste que contre la boue je pense
que aof courte va faire exploser la
pédophilie trafic humain ça existe c'est
sûr fac tu mets ton c'est pas des deux
c'est impossible que tout ça c'est juste
que cette avance quelque chose
cette avance qu' un tel lien lien avec
un tel pessimisme qui s'investit pas
compliqué et pas juste dire ça en hébreu
mais ça prend des preuves solides le
temps c'est souvent l'impression que
c'est basé sur pas grand-chose
disposition c'est sûr telles lettres et
histoire des acronymes son nom
comme si c'était un espèce de jeu de
puzzle qu'il fallait mais si penser
simplement d une enfant mais oui c'est
que le mont mdt du complot c'est comme
une énigme à résoudre
vers 6 maps il faut que ça reste ce que
ça reste du foot us h
c'est intéressant surtout tu saches que
je pense quand même que th général
mettons l'avenue la plus simple et
logique
ça risque d'être aimé ton steam et en
2001 les tours de caisse qui le plus
plausible
ça risque d'être la vérité qu'est ce qui
est vraiment plus compliqué
qui est vraiment plus un gros secret
quasiment impossible à garder c'est
sûrement possible mais je pense que ça
prend une photo parcouru un chemin aussi
je t'aime dans le tucson genre avec du
recul je te rendre au bout pour pouvoir
revenir ce que oui mais au foot est
comme plus de l'expérience pour réaliser
que finalement le site haussier souvent
l'avenue la plus réussie qui est la
solution en français bien résister
maintenant on dit du vrai journalisme
d'enquêté qui ont cru un sujet pour
laisser découvrir la vérité t il jamais
eu
puis je ne sois déjà parlé je peux même
que j'étais en ma faveur mais steam et
on les prêtres pédophiles depuis les
films et spotlight pas d'actualité celle
du journaliste qui ont vu est me semble
qu'il ya une problématique lui on va
creuser qui sont rendu compte de tout un
système qui laissait se passer et puis
qui qui qui ce qui laissait c'est arrivé
pile ont trouvé puis dans le fond on
était c'est une conspiration dans ce
sens qu'ils sont arrivés on le savait
pas puis c'était tout organiser puis
s'approche du monde que leur job s'est
trouvé ces affaires le métier c'est pas
le citoyen sur youtube que chez les
outils pour trouver c'est seulement la
force et que la fatigue des journalistes
comme ceux qui y ont pas plus accès à
l'information que moi notons témoin
mettons aussi le ski ce qui sépare ces
gens là qui font du journalisme banque
est plus il y en a de moins en moins à
cause de la crise des médias
des journalistes c'est leur travail de
faire sur ce que c'est parce de monsieur
madame tout le monde c'est juste une
rigueur puis une éthique de travail
parce qu'ils ont pas accès à plus
d'informations faut qu ils font les
mêmes démarches que moi je devrais faire
pour avoir accès au registre par exemple
aux autres mais c'est leur job c'est le
son format mais je veux dire en terme de
ce qui est quand même et on sait tous
que quand tu fais des recherches sur
quand tu parle aux famille quand tu
quand tu parles aux proches quand tu
recueil des des témoignages mais tant de
gens qui ont vu des dégâts des affaires
si ce travail là un peu de fun mais y en
a quand même pas mal les citoyens qui
résulte des affaires qui ont trouvé des
méthodes exemple jean nitoo par exemple
il ya le croate football c'est un john
doe un quinqua vêtir best jondo encore
retrouvé sans trouver son identité
ça fait déjà 25 ans avait posté qui
pille on l'appelait great falls un
t-shirt c1
c'est un citoyen enfin web ce look qu'on
appelle qui réussit une comédie web
internet c'est des passionnés qu'ils
échangent de l'information et puis
réussi à l'identifier en fait ça a été
comme ça hors de tout doute d'enfance
ont contacté sa famille puis c'était lui
enfin grâce à une vieille photo de lui
l'ont trouvé puis est en fait la ligne
comment ce seuil on savait quoi la
démarche me demandant à ce que tu sais
si tu peux nous raconter mes capacités
je pense que s'il y avait comme publier
des informations les citoyens avaient
publié des informations qui peut le
retrouver et pied et c'était par rapport
à 6 a publié des photos ou le dut du
câble est t'il quelqu'un qui avait dit m
et je pense je le connais c'est elle que
kalou sur l'honneur avec moi qui avais
réussi à trouver une faute d'une vieille
photo de cette gold et puis ça
ressemblait pas ce qu'il y avait comme
les cheveux frisés long et puis ben oui
en effet ça se ressemble et ont réussi à
trouver la mère d'hugo paix a dit ben
oui c'est mon fils mais ça fait genre 30
ans genre qui parti de la maison moi je
pensais qu'ils étaient qu'il voulait
juste pu revenir à la maison
kiwi costa lille puis on fait des tests
adn depuis cinq matches et qui est
deuxième histoire encore plus folle mais
ça le pot vraiment
ça le pas servi à grand chose mais c'est
la petite caylee en tenue et ça c'est
qu'elle est un technique on pense
qu'elle était assassiné par sa propre
mère triggering mais quand les les dos
en fait la morale été acquitté mais
quand les dossiers de la couronne sont
devenues publiques
encore là c'est tout un mouvement
citoyen qui ont conclu jade qui parce
qu'on a le temps de l'histoire une farce
mais charles un journaliste on
connaissait sans lui même les mêmes les
policiers les enquêteurs a mené ses
calculs passe ailleurs notre intérêt il
nous a donné ça m'obsède mais on ne
commençait des faits qui lui ont tout
épuisé s'appuie ont réussi à avoir dans
les dossiers que la mère et elle avait
cherché dans ses recherches google et
comment empoisonné jean roch leur forme
en fait on savait que c'était peu genre
y avait peut-être du too big to cloud
mais je sais pas pourquoi c'est pas
sortir les dents gens dans le procès
fait que c'est pas mal sûr qu'elles
allaient empoisonner sa fille les cartes
que ce soit la cause de la mort d'annick
a quitté la mère fait qu on le fait mais
on est pas mal sûr que ça c'est grâce
aux citoyens au web tout encore une fois
qui quand on est pas mal sûr que oui
elle le met bref c'est un match de lille
manquait quelque chose de cool qui nous
écoutent le fasse et votre historique
avec incognito l'aviation que je remette
incognito comme seul à pouvoir chercher
comment faire sauter une bombe avec ces
personnes même si c'est google chrome
c'est la page la q2 je suis dans des
pages de mime de philosophie la zone
inquiété en philo c'est comme tout cas
j'en étais qu'est ce que la vertu qu'est
ce qu'être quelle bonté subis tu avais
juste de 1 min tit comme genre dans le
chemin vers la vertu et épices comme des
lignes droites
plus tu vois genre croche genre
navigation privée haut de sa fenêtre
elle averti
c'est vraiment l'aviation privée c'est
vraiment juste pourrait pourtant pour
personne l'été pour éviter que quelqu'un
jetons data maison trouve ton hystérique
parce que c'est ça c'est quand éviter
qu'ils étaient criblés de béziers pour
ip exactions et wpp
personne ne sait quand il ya une
application comme pour pour cet excité
mais c'est se poser comme seul cd textos
en crypté l'un fait que je sais comment
ce texte là dessus pour que personne
trouve nos informations ces gens n'ont
pas folle qui on sait il n'y a rien que
tu peux une application qui donne
l'autre sur la posture qui en clip
traite et message au point où est ce que
personne peut les lire le nom le dit
c'est comme écrire messenger time
capsule la même chose s'est vraiment
rien cacher de l'information le 1 crypté
des textes ou non application laisse ces
gens si mettons ce texte à quelqu un
genre qui est que je joue dans le doubs
ma blonde gentiment 25 au lycée mais se
fera en séries puis envoie des médecins
des messages cryptés aspect qui me
retrouver tout dicté les documentaires
mais en très peu de temps après truc on
fait tout ce chemin ville pour vous non
ben moi j'ai essayé de commencer à
l'écouté puis j'ai écouté les premiers
15 minutes puis j'ai fait ici vont dire
des affaires que je me doute déjà j'ai
pas envie dans les langes passat à
l'heure mais en pleine fleur en pleine
face et tout mais ouais mais moi j'ai
trouvé que c'était vraiment je vois ma
petite fille premièrement toutes les
scènes toutes les scènes de fiction le
thé ou est-ce que tout jeune famille
prêter comme l'ado et de la croissance
elle s'est dégagée pour nous c'est pour
leur garde
ok mais parce que tu y mettons les
intervenants le montrent les temps
qu'ingrid le qui viennent parler de ce
qu'ils sont
paul intéressante si comme petit tombe
dans une joie de scènes de fiction
vraiment mal joué le coach fait comme
qu'est ce qui se passe mais je trouve
vraiment ce que leurs copains qui ont
mon titre féminin parce qu'au début j'ai
l'impression que c'est un film pour des
conspirations et les conspirationnistes
métaux
comme quoi même temps parce que ça
commence puis ça
craignent justement mettons que tu es un
peu considéré sonné ça va être créée qui
compte mais ton facebook et/ou dessous
parce que ça voudrait y ont toutes les
données sur toi et savent tout sur toi
puis tous qui t'envoient tous quitté
tennant l'honneur puisque tout tout de
suite et des stratégies pour que je sois
croton celte avec le les concertistes
veut très belles affiches contrôlée par
facebook contrôlées par les toons onana
puis après ce ça t'amène jusqu'à la fin
du film
ou est-ce que tu ouais mais la manière
justement dont il contrôle
c est en voyant du stock
conspirationnistes pc hôte radicalise en
fait j'ai l'impression que au début du
film tu dis pas qu'il faut jamais
départi d'être sûr parce que je contrôle
et puis à la fin tu sais ça ça dit il
contrôle en temps voyant cependant
faisant croire ce qu'on pense au fait
que je trouve ce fut vraiment un bon je
trouve ce shoot une bonne manière
justement de faire l'espèce de chemin de
pourquoi on nie tout le temps bombardée
de fausses informations
conspirationnistes parce que si il y en
a un qui dit jour de tous bords quand
même bref je suis plus excitant penser
qu'il ya un deepstack piqué on été
visité par des désirs lienne que qu'il
aura la vie et dans le tipi qui aurait
vraiment de téva l'impression que ça
peut éviter que certaines personnes
tombent dans ce panneau l'ops avec
quelqu'un qui tombe dans le panneau le
comprendre comment qui est tombé puis
remettra sans doute un peu des deux
ouais ça c'est fort intéressant mais pas
ce sujet j'ai trouvé que c'est pas tout
maîtriser le genre le guilly son maire
de hits en classe on va y envoyer une
photo de celtel fait les gens semblent
intéressés mais ça marche pas de membres
le meti le monde que cech mieux du monde
ti cats et reçoit une notification
logique après le film j'ai fait j'ai
fait que le fameux recommande j'ai
enlevé toute une éducation sont les
messages des ricains qui maigrit le tout
ce je le vois métier mettons j'ai pas
besoin de savoir
votre ami olivier à ajouter du contenu à
sa stone
savoir ce genre facebook des outils
distincts lui facebook après l'épisode
que mais ce parce que mettons mon ami
olivier tu es quelqu'un avec qui je
parle plus piketty proche de moi avec il
pense que ça m'intéresse août à faire de
même ou juste comme j'ai pu l'être et
c'est toutes les peines question genre
de oublie pas d'aller s'entraîner
aujourd'hui c'est juste des petites
affaires qui fait que ton téléphone tout
en train d'allumer tuant 30 days existe
l'attention parce que mad men sur
signification de votre entraîneur qui
est une bonne chose
j'obtiens de georges tu t'adresses à
d'autres choses mais ton juste en train
de travailler sur mon ordi plaisait plus
à ce genre ça sa pop qui fait que les
gens regardent peut finalement je loue
vraiment je voudrais ta g plus courus
par le disais c'est ça peut vraiment
faire ça c'est facilement j'écoutais le
podcast de jay de storm qui quitte avec
alexandre champagne ex japan il vient de
lancer sa fondation qui s'appelle centre
l'intelligence émotionnelle ciel
durables puis quoi mais c'est pour les
réseaux sociaux puis avec cette cavale
d'avoir de meilleures relations et les
réseaux sociaux puis il parle justement
du documentaire dans ce podcast le puits
en l'écoutant il m'est apparu une une
vision mais illumina c'est comme les
réseaux sociaux de contrôle faire un an
je pense que c'est un assez semaine il
propose des choses selon ses champs
d'intérêt mais techniquement il rien qui
t'oblige à regarder tes réseaux sociaux
constamment paix à faire guider ton
quotidien il rien ne t'oblige à choo-t
l'héroïne exactement sûr que c'est là
qu'il faut susciter ce faire mettons le
problème de dépendance à l'héroïne ce
facile de dire ton propre dépendance à
l'héroïne
mais je pense qu'on arrive dans le
moment où est ce qu'il faut se rendre
compte que c'est une vraie dépendance
button est besoin de trouver des
solutions de le nommer comme ceux de
dire oui les réseaux sociaux de contrôle
sur que la seule raison pour que les
réseaux sociaux sites de chaussures de
contrôle parce que tu y vas c'est parce
que tu es constamment reçu naissance qui
est accepte les notifications c'est
parce que tu te fais tu te fais diriger
parce que tu es là tu recherches
photo vd de rick tocchet cse mais c'est
juste papa juste derrière quelqu'un
capable de jeu mais joue pas passer
maintenant mais tu peux dire réalises
que tu as un problème de joie la
première est assez seule la première
étape obstacles je pense que je pense
que de réaliser cela dit roy mais si tu
trouveras mac le problème c'est que les
réseaux sociaux de contrôle peut-être
que le problème est aussi que tu as
besoin des réseaux sociaux
mais ces petits tout le temps dessus
trouvez vous que c'est certaine période
de votre vie que vous n'êtes plus sur
les médias sociaux
ça c'est vraiment foule des périodes de
votre vie vous sentez plus vulnérables -
organiser mois ces foules j'ai certaines
périodes que chez genre monde sujet par
ce genre cinq ans aujourd'hui quasiment
sur instagram pilote période que j'ai
loupé de la journée puis c'est pourquoi
les périodes qu'est-ce qui fait ce matin
s'est pas écarté plus s'occuper du 7e
rapport avec soin sont maintenus serait
plus occupé qui d'autre que cela mon
dieu je suis le calme aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas si c'est cyclique un peu pour
moi mais je sais qu'en ce moment je suis
vraiment un effort conscient de ne pas
aller tout le temps sur mon site
vraiment vraiment vraiment le comme je
fais vraiment attention je laisse dans
d'autres pièces ses deux mandats à
l'elysée c'est de mettre en mode avion
quand je vois courir mais ton camp quand
je suis dans une bonne voie ce que je
veux pas seul j'ai vraiment dans un
processus où est-ce qu'à 5 heures
je le fais en maintient cinq tireurs je
reçois plus de messages c'est puis je
sais vraiment d'être pour toute la
fraîcheur le tuba et si je ferme mes
temps je me dis je jouais pas je réponds
pas de découvrir vos potions s'est
activement faire quelque chose sur
instagram apport jeu pour les widgets et
de travailler mais ton nom puis je vais
pas non plus essayer d'aller magasiner
des affaires j'essaie de garder seul
pipi dans un effort vraiment conscient
depuis qui t'envoient le dimanche soir
une le temps des craintes a réparé par
jour depuis que j'ai vu je veux à peu
près je suis pas trois mois puis j'ai
fait il faut le réaliser comme se dit il
faudrait les amener quelques temps un
problème je pense que mme et on n'écoute
al documental documente at il dit quand
même
tessi groupe sis est peut-être exagéré
y participent c'est atypique pas le
meilleur en tant que film film et ça
peut faire que ça de leur petit créé
manquer où j'ai peut-être un problème de
dépendance je pense que le problème
quand les semences retient b dans
d'autres sociétés dans nos générations
oui je parle de la marque on peut faire
une corrélation presque direct comment
bien tu veux quand même temps tu passes
ton simplement témoin il ya des journées
où est ce que je suis une merde je me
sens pas by juju qui est notre petit jeu
c'est pas toi tu es aussi un tir de
puits inspectés sortant daudet et des
plus hautes ont fait qu'ils ne l'étaient
pas du tout je l'étais pas ben oui mais
l'anxiété l'anxiété et chorale els à
l'anxiété vote de père de ckoi
l'expression on sait l'importance que tu
donnes aux réseaux sociaux dans le fond
de la façon que moi je lis je
l'interprète l'été mettant en réseau ce
1 1 des réseaux sociaux qui me crée
aucune anxiété c'est facebook parce que
facebook je m'en fous je n'ai jamais
utilisé mon facebook et j'ai les mêmes
amis que j'avais avant au dg rien fait
sur facebook leur hygiène exact et je
suis juste même mon compte personnel
avec mes amis de natation du rouge et or
puis le même cercle de personnes
s'effectuera comme bhp mais instagram
effectivement plus accorder d'importance
à ce plus à me jouer dans tête puis ça
me décale celtique et l'a emmené c'est
juste de faire kiczek pissos la décision
que j'ai prise de le faire
progressivement mais de le faire quand
même de juste laisser aller c'est plus
avoir la pression de publier pu avoir la
pression de la cuy avons l'impression
que comme en déplacement quasiment plus
bas
moi ces mots si c'était famille au caire
entre je dis bon peut-être plus un vrai
projet sur ce que je dis sa voix comme
anti chasse aux nobles a dit baye drège
répond pas tant que cela dit je réponde
mieux que je peux plus dire qu'ils
étaient ya pas de moi c'est ma santé
mentale
gt5 de même c'est ma santé mentale
c'est vrai le qu'ils répondent presque
pas mais georges peu plus corsé mais je
trouve ce christmas ce métier john games
est un bon exemple
j'organise ultra polarisant il discute
souvent un truc qui font réagir beaucoup
de tout les côtés
sauf que lui il ne lis jamais les
commentaires avec lui ce qui fait un
existe juste parce que lui décide de le
faire tic ont un peu maintenant un outil
mettons lahoud qui a son compte
instagram mais qui quand l'ourson et ses
amis est suivi par cent mille personnes
mais il suffisait récent exemple je te
raconte priver quiconque aurait
peut-être qu'en privé qu'on connaît pas
pour l'état beau tacle de temps en temps
sauf que sinon son compte c'est jusqu'à
s'est rien passé
s'il suit personne fait ça si je trouve
ça quand même tout petit je trouve ça
quand même cool en même temps tu dis ça
prend une relation avec le monde qui tu
tombes
mais comment tout ça lance jarden
beaucoup le match parce que j'en donne
beaucoup ce jeu fourni une vidéo par sa
mère et je publie des photos des fois je
serai pas en commentaire mais jamais ils
tous que joe rogan dit pisam est
vraiment resté puis j'essaie vraiment de
l'appliquer t il c'est un paquet avec le
graph personnes puis dégustation du thé
et le cash commencé à faire dévier ou
scientifique de films le monde et
farouche il y avait tout à avoir des
commentaires de ce puits j'organise il
faut que tu apprennes le poste
c'est un truc qui me later regarde pas
ce qui se passe à quai
piti témoin simone qui est beau temps
actif sur instagram ou quoi que ce soit
avant je pense qu'une photo pi le chaos
après cinq minutes et à bas prix de
détail
bilger qui est ce qu'un petit fils les
podcasts sortais c'était comme qui j'ai
tout le temps whilst anciens pour moi
mettez en anglais que si nous aide aussi
à faire serait juste de juste de poster
de quoi puis tim et on met donc mais
d'autres frais pour le commentateur de
répondre aux commentaires et est assez
peu de prendre trois minutes est
ajournée il répondra tout le monde a pu
apprécier mais c'est de tout le temps
les riches et qui offre à chaque cinq
minutes au rang de la commune viewed as
com ainsi qu'aux bien sûr c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui te rend fou qui transforme
il faut pas passer ton truc dépose puis
tu le regardes c'est clairement ça c'est
vraiment une bonne façon de se garder
une solitude oui mais moi c'est sur
twitter je pense que je réponds plus
points non mais c'est que man is ses
miches et toutes les youtube à toutes
les influences au recasement on dit
propre succession de dépressions des
salles eux pas de sens qui se regarde
sur youtube mais les huit bars
américains un français tout le monde des
problèmes c'est oui une corrélation
rooney médias sociaux bissap aux deux
sens sur certains à huy est quoi le pire
c'est alex champagne aussi qui dissout
dans le podcast a exigé il parlait de
tout le monde aussi le besoin
d'approbation la personne qu'il le peut
le fait qu'il dit c'est vraiment facile
de tomber dans le panneau de fer puis il
dit même même lui le fait de moi moi ph
les fait aussi ses défenseurs posté une
photo puis les likes m'apaise me font du
bien les plus ça fait du bien
puis c'est de l'approbation de quelqu'un
d'autre mais c'est d'essayer d'arrêter
de ses fonctions et a fonctionné comme
ça tu mets ton demandant que du podcast
le type j'imagine que c'est un peu même
précis pour tes vidéos c'est faisons la
meilleure chose qu'on peut faire
qui pis juste de faire la meilleure
chose que tu peux faire devrait être
assez en termes de comment ça te fait
sentir et si tu devrais pas avoir besoin
de l'approbation si toi même tu es fier
ce que tu as fait surtout de
l'approbation par autant de monde on né
peut ne pas évoluer pour être vu et
liker par des dizaines d'été des
milliers d'exilés rockstore il virait
sur le top qui avait dix mille personnes
les applaudir des x men d un franc
succès des millions là avant le terme et
on sait mettant justement en privé ton
tu lis et ses pieds le tipi c'est comme
il m'a jamais dit un groupe citoyen 50
personnes et puis dans l'iss a dit et
qui peut entretenir max mettront des
relations ti connaissance avec 150
personnes à humain piloter après ce
thème et on vole pas si longtemps tout
le monde avait 2000 amis facebook mais
la presse c'est comme 18 par cent mille
personnes c'est s'opposer à des jeux de
2000 amis facebook centaines de millions
imaginez ça c'est qu'on pratique se fait
il qu'on n'est pas capable de saisir
c'est comme je pense pas qu'on y est on
y est constitué pour pour des leaks ces
classes où est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on
suit qu'est ce que c'est pour toi qu'est
ce qu'on fait maintenant le monde qui
veulent qu'ils veulent plus de toi
youtube
j'espère atteindre 500 milles avant de
partir c'est bientôt tu approches on lis
ton livre
ouais et garder les hivers des petits
projets qui s'en viennent
gates garde l'oeil ouvert pour le hippie
le vert pour d'autres projets une
délégation emmenée par la baltique ont
été par la suite prononcé le mot c'est
ma santé mentale
oui comment à votre talent à l'histoire
moyenne une souris mais oui on peut en
parler mais je voudrais que mes il est
vraiment qu'ils écoutent plus la
coqueluche du ballon et va en fait j en
ai parlé sur le caucase jean-philippe
puis on y parlait sur ma chaîne ya pas
longtemps mais j'ai été récemment
diagnostiqués avec de la bipolarité
bipolarité type 2 fait que c'est
vraiment léger et plus j'apprends à des
lyrics ce n'était même pas dans le fait
que c'est quoi c'est quand même temps
comment te décrirais ce que les
symptômes se côtoient ça marche et
margot j'ai eu comme un mini haye qui a
été suivi par 1 min down
j'ai eu deux épisodes mixte même pas
mais se cache t ici l'année passée
j'étais comme dans un mini heim était
c'est tellement léger que genre et
bipolaires de type 2 il ya tellement
d'aspects qu'il remarque même pas c'est
parce qu'on s'imagine dès janvier pas là
on n'ose imaginer
qui a demandé ce qu'il faut c'est
souvent vip à leur type ok ça va mener à
une hospitalisation
ben moi comment ça s'est manifestée
c'était surtout des symptômes physiques
et je me rappelle j'avais c'était le
change
c'est vraiment ils vont être car ici me
suivent partout dans tant de paris mais
moi j'avais vraiment des papillons dans
le ventre mais ça la durée comme trois
modes temps le métier des papillons en
langue comme un trac dans un quartier
précis de quelque chose mais celle-ci
papillon le fun déjà georges et de
l'énergie où jean papillon commun les
papillons sont fun quand ça dure trois
courses la dénonciation le temps mais
c'est comme le funk le couple tenait le
public ça m'a empêché de me jeter car de
m'endormir mais je me réveillais genre à
2 heures du matin puis j'étais prêt à me
rendre jusqu'à 50 matin selon le feeling
d'avoir pris trop café tout le temps je
ne savais pas que je prend de la coke
mais georges de ça c'est comme si on
triche ça coûte moins de trois mois puis
mettez jamais pris de drogue je prenais
kampot café parce que j'étais folle
je dormais pas beaucoup puis je mangeais
pas beaucoup non plus je sentais comme
pas la fin puis c'est ce que c'était mon
lancement de livre effectué ma famille
était comme vtt sur un an à il était une
fois une petite billie des affaires ça
va penser et pied après mais j'arrive au
mexique puis là j'ai quand même connu un
temps puis comme une mauvaise nouvelle
bon c'est ça mais entre une mauvaise
nouvelle que j'ai comme ça me lancer sur
un groupe d'hommes mais un gros dans le
poteau j'avais passé suicide en quoi que
ce soit de quoi ça mais j'étais comme ça
philippe fait que j'aille voir une
psychologue qui aimait ça et c'est ce
qui est bizarre parce qu'elle me tout de
suite diagnostiqué ah ben je pense que
tu es bipolar type 2 mais genre gens
apprennent qu'ils ménagent en chine
après un peu comme un cinquième
mais avant dans ta vie je dirais skis et
bâtons sa chance au tpi à ça explique
tout ça peut pas surpris sa note
surprise mais en fait moi j'ai trois
personnes sans les nommer mais dans ma
famille immédiate qui sont vit pas là en
fait de se tirer d'un gâteau mais trois
personnes deux personnes ne dit pas la
même à grand mère en fait était à lui
des chocs au cerveau choc électrique
le bateau non mais n'a pas fait les
choses à vous aujourd'hui ce genre un
dernier recours loin d'aller seul
théâtre que bref qui est fait - plaît
mais tout de suite
au mexique la soirée mais maman vont y
voir un psychiatre
si ça prend jean trois mois avant
d'avoir animé la base c'était comme la
soierie même qu elle aussi avait tout de
suite prescrit comme du lithium le médoc
est bipolaire type 2 c'est ça en fait
mais laisse entrer dans les détails mais
si ça en fait les bipolaires et on a
tendance à comme peut prendre le
médicament parce que j'ai des prix et
puis après je t'ai abel ça va bien
dirigé plusieurs étaient trop mou
lithium ça le bien fonctionné j'ai
commencé la natation qui est je
mangerais bien j'ai dit au final si je
pense que si je prends soin de moi
touche pas je vais être capable vraiment
sorti loges comme j'ai eu un épisode mix
qu'en fait c'est ce qui t'est les gens
me par an on s'imagine que ses droits et
des groupes de danse qui est là j'ai été
confronté à confronter un épisode mix
qui je savais pas que ça existait puis
c'est ça pour n'en parle jamais de tubes
c'est quoi ces fous qui s'illustra enfin
parce qu'on pense que leurs enfants ici
on pense que des rails c'est le fun mais
en fait c'est vraiment pas tout le temps
le fun puis c'est ça on n'en parle
jamais si j'avais tout les symptômes de
raï encore une fois je me sentais comme
si j'avais pris le genre
c'est ce qu'a fait le ou de la gauche ça
n'a pas de sens ce genre les gens qui
check et bien je n'ai pas gardé dormir
plus tard quand même temps j s
ça me fait ça j'arrête pendant une
semaine
deux thèmes j'avais les mains moites
leva c'était fou qui même césar me
parler georges était pas je t'ai pas car
de l'écouté le partage ta mère je touche
packard de t'ecouter le sergent tout ce
que tu me dis je consens prix d'enfants
même pas capable d'écouter une émission
j'ai bien compris mais j'étais pas de
bonne humeur comme la fois d'avant en
fait j'étais tellement et mais j'étais
peu triste mais george avait pas de
motivation j'ai en fait c'est ça j'avais
toutes les symptômes d'un rail mais et
toutes les salles mais l'énergie comme
de dinde en fait fait que ce et en gros
ce qui m'est arrivé c'est que là j'ai
repris mon lycée en fait bill autre
chose mais ça c'était déjà pris mon
lithium et qui est le genre un gros
épisode mais en fait ma psy qu'hier
c'était vraiment pas une personne très
compétente parce que j'ai voulu changer
médicaments le sait peut-être avec est
trop long à expliquer mais j'ai voulu
changer médicaments bien me dire qu'ils
posent problème le j'ai pris ce j'ai
pris mon estime cependant comme deux
mois j'ai voulu changer mais de 48 ma
psy car ça me dit ok pas de problème
c'était au mois d'août enfants que
stagner mais dit pas de problème au lieu
de me dire on va diminuer ton lithium
graduellement el mehdi ben les fronts
coupons lithium puis angers médicament
ce con tu peux jamais façonnent le corps
il
non ça ouais mais je sais pas je pense
qu'elle est prigent son diplôme de
psychiatres dans une cours des céréales
à le fond sur mexico mais ça je sais pas
parce que dehors de psychiatres du
mexique le terrain comme lorsque sam
gd compensant nous le jaish le mettais
mon histoire biz le genre j'ai des
compensées lemay
ça a été le pire épisode de ma vie le
module tu étais un autre épisode mais ça
allait tellement été intense le sheed à
16 ans je pense que trouveront
m'hospitaliser le genre ouais bah j'ai
subi pendant deux semaines genres entre
que bref fait que tu te tue la tenue des
jo
consultez ici non plus j'ai revu une
deuxième bombe ne sais pas parce qu'il
est au mexique que tout le monde est
incompétent je les ai vus comme quatre
fois et la mort fait comme un autre
diagnostic parce que j'étais comme puce
ou rejeter comme est ce que je suis
vraiment bipolaire parce que c'était
super rapide d'un diagnostic qui a pris
comme 4 5 4 5 séances on a rencontré me
dire où il tue ton diagnostic est bon
parce qu'encore au tj raconter mes
symptômes bien voyante mais c'est parce
qu'en même temps quelqu'un de bipolaire
ou quelqu'un qui souffre de
schizophrénie ont qu'il n'y a pas de
test sanguin dans le cerveau ou en fait
si selon les symptômes selon des
expériences se fait que mme et il ya des
symptômes assez clair si tonton manque
de sommeil
c'est ce qu'il faut que je checke moi
surtout cesser ce genre deux trois jours
sans dormir de trois jours sans manger
trail à ma vie privée est là m'avait
coupé est vraiment la caféine l'alcool
faut vraiment je fasse attention à
sûrement j'avais tendance à bord du
monster le jir mais c'est parce que
c'est ce que c'est ça qui est proche
c'est que libye parlant on s'imagine
toujours été si tellement c'est
tellement et
différents pour chacun mais l'hôte et on
va s'imaginer quelqu'un dit par akiva
dépensé tout son argent qui veut qu'ils
vont rentrer en psycho c'est que mais
c'est tellement tellement c'est super
léger bond des fonctionnels jeux wii
forget espère organiser moi ça va être
vraiment juste des symptômes physiques
c'est les papillons moi j'ai senti suite
dans le ventre en vente
je vais prendre comme plus de celles
fille se jouer c'est surtout sorti ses
10 petits trucs dans moins de
concentration mais ça va pas affecter
mon temps que ce monde étudiant peut
dire qu'on ne voit tout le temps posé
des salles fille sur cinq y aller mais
c'est quelque chose qu'ici qui peut se
développer large audit ou d'enfoncer
tout le temps le bain c'est moi mais
quand je moi j'avais fait un épisode
assez important important pendant que
j'avais fait une dépression dans la
vingtaine à l'université puis un autre
épisode laisse entrer dans les détails
que je pense que j'avais fait un rail en
taille aussi adversité qui avait duré
comme deux semaines fait que avec du
recul je pense que c'était ce nom mais
c'est souvent dans la vingtaine que ça
se développe la bip bip à la paix dans
le fond si tous foutus jubel dans le
fond bonne hygiène de vie et médication
pour que ça va vous regarder souvent le
sentimental si sommeil
et pas juste une solution peu juste les
médicaments puissent pas juste manger
des légumes ce nom est là m'avait dit
l'enfant tour deuxième médicament c'est
ce même genre tu peux se passe une nuit
blanche l'a dit ça peut déclencher une
nuit blanche ne peut pas dormir le sais
ça fait que metz c'est sûr mais moi je
sors je racontais j ai je dit c'est quoi
qui aurait pu déclencher sa sculpture
pas j'ai essayé du pote ça se retire
parce que j'ai essayé tel de dreux ça ce
petit que dans ma ville ça ce petit que
les médias sociaux je sens à ce que tu
fais parce qu'il me semble ça a commencé
quand j'ai commencé à avoir du succès
sur youtube on l'a dit non mais ça peut
être un mélange de tout se met ça sur
wii c'est parce que c'est arrivé quand
j'ai lancé mon livre mon épisode rail
paix a dit c'est sûr que d'être rigole
c'est sûr que le tt gens pour mexique
était un genre en dehors de tarot tienne
tu vivais des grosses émotions fortes
que ça se peut aussi a dit en a qui
peuvent pas prendre de café ou parce que
ça va déclencher comme une manif ça va
déclencher une manie autres facs et
c'est vraiment assez spécial c'est
l'addition de peut-être quelque chose
qu'ils étaient prêts existants pis des
circonstances moi et ça j'en ai même
j'avais lu parce que le jeter je prends
fallen il faut là dessus je me suis
acheté un livre petit et j'essaie
vraiment de prendre soin de moi tu es
petite scie sauteuse faire fois
l'attenté le juge jeunes a rejeté paulo
en ce moment j'essaie de faire de
l'exercice et puis lui a donné une fille
sont raidies le jeu sera semble-t-il des
bipolaires montré une fissure et
éradiquer l à chaque fois qu'il tombe en
amour et ça a déclenché des manies c'est
fou quand même parce que dans ce qui
sonne oui mais le bloc une nouvelle
rassurante
c'est sûrement un bain ils s'adorent des
baby pour man il que c'est plus léger
mais c'est fou parce que ça déclenche en
dessous est de prendre un billet
merci à jal jusqu'au site monde qui
écoute ce qui je sais pas quels conseils
leur dernier mais vous pisse escarpins à
les consulter sur nos chaînes non merci
[Musique]